welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and one division sequel Agatha coven of
chaos recently had a new title revealed
by one actor on the set but with this
being the third title that we've gotten
for this project what could be the
Common Thread among all these titles
that could give us a hint as to what the
plot of this long-awaited show is even
going to be I think I might have an idea
as to what Agatha will be up to in
Westview so let's dive into all these
details that we know of shall We Men our
babies but first like always you
rocksusbirch.com got all the coolest the
best clothing items for your nerdy heart
to wear on on top of that nerdy heart
because you don't want your heart to
wear clothes or else you'll die we got
hoodies shirts hats all sorts of really
dope really fun stuff over in Europe
doesn't merch.com so pick something up
for you or someone that you love today
alright so a recent image posted to
Instagram by 19 year old actor Joe Locke
on the set of Agatha coven of chaos
shows the back of a chair that has a
completely different and previously
unannounced working title for the
production Agatha of West is the newest
title for this production that we know
of after Marvel Studios initially
announced the show as Agatha House of
Harkness on Disney plus day in 2021 only
to change the title a few months later
to Agatha coven of chaos at San Diego
Comic-Con in July 2022 a show that will
apparently be incorporating a lot of the
same citizens of Westview that were
traumatized while Wanda maximoff was
working out some personal stuff in one
division with the return of David Payton
as John Collins AKA herb David langel as
Phil Jones Asif Ali abalash as Tandon
Norm Emma Caulfield Ford as Sarah AKA
Dottie Deborah Joe Rupp as Sharon Davis
aka Mrs Hart in the hex Amos Glick
returning as Dennis the mailman Ryan
breitman as the sheriff and Kate Forbes
returning as evanora Harkness AKA
Agatha's mom which of course makes sense
considering where we last left Agatha
off at the end of one division with
Wanda cursing Agatha to remain within
the confines of West View New Jersey
seemingly Forever Wait wait
oh yeah hun you live here now but what
is particularly of note here is the
confirmation of actress Kate Forbes
returning as leader of the Old Salem
coven avanora Harkness after we saw her
get turned into a raisin of Waverly
Place by agava in a one division
flashback because I feel like her
inclusion specifically combined with
what we know about this production in
Agatha and the comics can give us a big
idea of what Marvel Studios is planning
for this show a plan that I believe
leads to Agatha turning the entire town
of West View New Jersey into her own
coven of chaos I think that is the link
between all these three titles Westview
will be the new house of Harkness and
her new coven of chaos at the same time
because if you go back to that scene
with Agatha and elevenor Harkness having
their last mother-daughter disagreement
and extremely important detail about
Agatha's overall character motivations
begins to manifest as we learn that a
crown of energy is awarded to the most
powerful of witches in the world the
witches with the most magical authority
to lead a coven of their own someday I
can be good
no you cannot
I strongly believe that Agatha herself
ever since the days of her youth craved
power so much in major parts to wanting
to be the leader of a coven just like
her mom we see this kind of proven
subtly in one division episode 8 when
Agatha takes her mother's brooch off of
her dead body to wear for seemingly
hundreds of years after she kills her
and in the one division finale when
Agatha gasped at the site of Wanda's
crown of chaos energy on her head
pointing to Wanda's dominion over chaos
Magic
give me your power like Agatha really
wants to be in charge because much like
the MCU is full of people with daddy
issues I believe Agatha Harkness is an
extremely curious person with serious
mommy issues coupled with a really bad
control problem and all of those factors
together will lead this Harkness on
house arrest to make herself the leader
of her own coven of Chaos in Westview
effectively turning West View New Jersey
into a modern day MCU version of a new
Salem and a big reason why I say this is
because Agatha was actually the head of
a secret town of magic users called New
Salem in the comics because after years
of persecution The Witches of Salem
decided to leave the eyes of mankind and
form a secret community of 666 witch
members where they could practice their
magic away from the judgmental eyes of
regular Mortals and everything was great
and cool until the strongest witches in
the town called Salem 7 decided to
portray Agatha and freaking burn her at
the stake which was super messed up but
then she came back later with uh via
unexplained means so I guess it's fine
it's totally fine if you kill somebody
but they come back to life it's like you
never did it right to jail right away
but at any rate knowing this background
of Agatha being the leader of a secret
coven of witches in the comics and
knowing that Agatha in the MCU has a
reputation for bending the rules placed
upon her I think that all of these
returning actors in one division are
going to be given a piece of that
forbidden chaos knowledge that Agatha
learned from the dark hole because you
gotta remember everybody just because
the dark hole books in darkhold Castle
were destroyed in Multiverse of Madness
those forbidden spells of absorbing
magic power still live inside of the
mind of Agatha archimus and since we
know from the first Doctor Strange movie
that pretty much anyone who is willing
to learn magic can become a master of
the Mystic Arts I think we might see all
of these people of Westview who recently
held hostage by a witch who was
depressed and gone mad be lured in by
the promise of learning to protect
themselves from such witches and other
magical threats by Agatha Harkness
herself gradually gifting dark powers to
her neighbors over time in order to
build her own Coven in Westview just
like her mom because she just wants to
be her mom however much like she was in
the comics I feel like Agatha will teach
the wrong citizens of Westview the dark
spells of the dark hold which might just
lead to a West View power struggle for
leadership of this coven of chaos and I
can see Marvel Studios and Kevin feige
going this direction in an attempt to
get Agatha to see just how dangerous the
dark hole was and just how difficult
being the leader of a coven actually is
allowing for Agatha to finally feel
guilt over what she did to her mom and
countless other witches over centuries
because if you think about it her mom
was literally just trying to protect the
world from her daughter who learned the
secrets of the dark hole and if you
learn anything from Multiverse of
Madness is if you read that freaking
book you need to be put to death because
you're gonna do some wild [__] I feel
like this would be a very logical way to
transform Agatha's character from a
full-on villain to the kind reformed
helper of Wanda maximoff and the
Fantastic Four family that she
originally was in the comics but yes
that is what I believe to be the Common
Thread between all these three titles at
the house of Harkness Agatha Covenant
chaos and Agatha of Westview all are
pointing towards Westview becoming a new
coven of chaos that will be led by one
act of the Harkness but again thank you
guys like always for watching this video
you can follow me at Mass retainment on
Twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [__] and really fun theories but
most importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the social
media thank you guys so much for
watching and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]